[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
nor as I prefer to think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death where me and my brother John give
you dubious advice answer your questions
and bring you all the week's news to
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon I mixed it
up just a little bit in the middle there
did you catch it
yeah I'm sure that that's just
incredibly exciting for our listeners
how are you Hank I'm good I would like a
sandwich do you have one I don't and
also I can't transmit sandwiches over
the the internet tubes I apologize for
that but that's one of the things that
the internet doesn't do well yet it
doesn't we can 3d print things across
space and time which is nice but we
cannot yet 3d print sandwiches at least
not edible ones no no and even if you
even if you could John would you
download a sandwich
yeah no I would I never found that to be
a compelling marketing campaign there
was an era where the movie studios were
like you wouldn't download a pizza don't
download movies or music and I was like
of course I would definitely order pizza
no yeah how do ya know could I do that I
mean I would download a pizza way before
I would download a movie right yeah like
in the case of a movie or music I
understand that they're their creators
involved who need to be compensated in
the case of the pizza as far as I can
tell pizzas just come from space I don't
think that there are I think that they
grow on pizza trees I believe they do
they grow on pizza trees and they get
picked by pizza farmers so I guess the
pizza farmer needs to make something
yeah but I don't know anyway the point
is you can't download a pizza or a
sandwich for that matter I feel that we
should move on to the the short poem for
the day I use what if you want to know
all right this is a poem by Claude McKay
Hank I don't know if you're familiar
with his work one of the major poets of
the Harlem Renaissance but for some
reason much less famous than Langston
Hughes and some of the other Harlem
Renaissance writers but I I don't know I
really like Claude McKay this plumbs
called if we must die and it is a great
American poem about the african-american
struggle for civil rights
if we must die let it not be like hogs
hunted and penned in an inglorious spot
while round us bark the mad and hungry
dogs making their mock at our accursed
lot if we must die a lettuce nobly died
so that our precious blood may not be
shed in vain then even the monsters we
defy shall be constrained to honor us
though dead Oh kinsmen we must meet the
common foe though far outnumbered let us
show us brave and for their thousand
blows deal one deathblow what though
before us lies the open grave like men
will face the murderous cowardly pack
pressed to the wall dying but fighting
back if we must die by Claude McKay
wonderful thanks John I mean I feel like
that's that was a poem about death it
wasn't that depressing eh or it is
depressing but it's it's there's
something defiant about it that I like I
like poems that are defiant toward death
and towards systemic injustice I think
that defiance is probably the right the
right response so yeah I love that book
well thank you for sharing it with us
okay we got a question from Nikki who
asks a dear Hank and John last night a
few of my old friends from college and I
got together for a low-key dinner party
somehow we started to compare ourselves
from two characters from Saved by the
Bell I thought for sure they were gonna
agree that I was screech the nerdy
awkward one but they saw me as more of a
Lisa the fashionable cool one though
both screech and Lisa are fun characters
they are just about as opposite as could
be on that show
you've talked before about
self-identification but what about
outside perspectives are we more who we
think we are or are we more who others
think of us also do you think we ever
stop questioning who we are I have some
questions for Nikki to start off yeah ah
do you like wind your friend group forms
an impromptu unexpected rock band do you
play the bass guitar because that would
be a Lisa turtle thing yeah that's very
Lisa and also Lisa yeah when
all of your friends spend a summer
working at a resort do you instead just
be a guest at that resort because of how
your father is extraordinarily wealthy
because that would be a Lisa thing
that's so Lisa
so Lisa so so maybe those are maybe
you're maybe you just not as familiar
with Saved by the Bell as you think you
might be you did in fact say in your
question Saved by the Bell characters
which is just not what the show is
called
so I'm questioning your authority on the
entire understanding of safe birth Bell
and and the mythology here but to the to
the larger question Hank which i think
is probably at the center of things not
I don't think that as I understand it
anyway our podcast isn't a rehash of all
17 seasons of Saved by the Bell
but is instead a place where our
listeners come for extraordinarily
dubious advice let me submit that you
cannot actually separate who you are
from how people see you because identity
is something that is hashed out in
social spaces so you are both who you
believe yourself to be and what others
believe you to be and I don't think that
you can in the end really separate those
things because I think that identity and
personhood are it's things that we kind
of confer upon each other I I agree I
also think there's a possibility that
your friends do see you as a screech
more of a screech but they just don't
want to let you know that because
screeches screech you know maybe maybe
they're maybe they're trying to beat me
be like yeah you're more yeah you're
really you're likely say it's uh you
know fashionable and cool I don't know I
don't think there's anything wrong with
being a screech oh I absolutely agree
obviously Nicki doesn't either but maybe
her friends maybe if maybe they see it
as a kind of insult to be a screech
I wouldn't want I have to say want to
associate myself too closely with the
actor who played screech but as first or
honestly the actress who played Lisa
turn I'm not very familiar with her work
outside of Saved by the Bell but but as
for the characters themselves I think
like one of the things that makes Saved
by the Bell so special as a TV show is
that you know in its sort of broad
stroked way of approaching the
American high school it gave us who
those of us who weren't yet in high
school like a framework through which to
think of our own high school experience
once we were there and I think that's in
the end like what's so valuable about
all of those shows and it's why there's
such a responsibility to kind of create
those archetypes in ways that will
resonate with people it's not so much
that you need to create the archetype
for the student who's already in high
school you need to create the archetypes
thoughtfully and carefully for the
students who will later use them in
analyzing their own high school
experience indeed that's I think that
was insightful John oh well thanks that
I appreciate that let's move on to
another question Hank this one's from
Frieda who writes dear John and Hank can
birds fly in space
well Frieda can anything not fly in
space I would argue Hank that birds
cannot fly in space on account of how
once they are in space they are dead so
let's just assume that there's a bird
that has a little spacesuit on its face
and it's flying around and for the skids
it's good summer some way of making sure
it making it able to breathe and stuff a
bird could would would flap around as if
it were flying in space it would not be
able to control itself in space because
there's no air molecules to push against
as a relative vacuum out there so so
birds fly by pushing against all the
molecules in the fluid of the air they
would not be able to fly in space though
recently I was watching the expanse
which is a very good show that is on
Syfy network and and they one of the lot
of the show takes place on Ceres which
has a very low gravity and they have
birds there and they do fly they just
fly very differently and they flap their
wings far less than they would have to
here on earth that sounds like a great
show that's pretty cool not exactly my
kind of television program and I only
have time to watch about one TV show
every four months so unless you highly
highly recommend it I don't think I'm
gonna get into it well if you're gonna
pick one I think I would pick the
magicians as a new one which was written
by a friend of yours I believe
or the book was written by I do I do
like the author of that book Lev
Grossman very much yes
i right now I'm watching Jessica Jones
hmm which is giving me terrible dreams
yep and I'm going to finish watching
that and then I might give up on TV
until the Americans returns to take a
break from television in advance of my
excitement about the returning Americans
well I am also all caught up on
Americans
so I'm also looking forward to that I
think we've got another question this
one comes from Dylan who asks Dear John
and Frank I am Dylan I'm six years old
in February I like listening to the show
with my mom and dad I have a question
about lava combined with the Sun if you
could get lava to the Sun what would
happen to it
best wishes Dylan first off Dylan let me
just say that as a parent of a
six-year-old I am very impressed with
your podcast listening habits my own son
refuses to listen to this podcast so
thank you additionally hello Dylan my
name is Hank
Frank's fine though you could get fined
I prefer I prefer if you call him Frank
Dylan alright if you if you could get
lava to the Sun I would probably get
even hotter than it already is
so lavas hot but the Sun is hotter
especially on the inside so that lava
would would get so hot that it would go
from what it is now which has is a rock
that got so hot that it turned to a
liquid then when a liquid gets even
hotter like when you boil water that
liquid turns into a gas so that that
rock would go from from liquid as lava
and then it would turn from from if you
can believe this from lava into rock gas
so that is what that is that as part of
what at least would happen if you
brought lava to the Sun Wow Rock gas
would be a pretty good name for a rock
band yeah no uh actually have you ever
heard of lahpet Amane no lahpet Amane
was a performer who would play music
with his but he was able to do a thing
that would allow him to take air into
his body and then and then expel it and
he was able to play music with with
farts and that that my friend is another
form of rock gas sure Dylan's parents
are delighted just delighted that we
have shared that with the world all
right I have another question ja do I
hear yes
this one's from Camilla who asks dear
Hank and John after blowing one's nose
as we all do why does one look into the
Kleenex to see what's there am I
expecting to see something unusual
they're just wondering well I can answer
that question for myself I am expecting
to see something unusual there I'm
checking to see what kind of snot did I
produce you know is there blood in there
is it clear as if colored is that green
is it yellow yeah this is brownish did
you get any like real good hunks of some
far their reasons for concern is there
evidence of my forthcoming death inside
that tissue there's a famous line in
John Keats is God are you seriously
quoting Keats I read in response to a
question about stand right now full line
of iambic pentameter he he costs and as
I recall you can actually see the drop
of blood in the on the page like he
coughed blood came out and this was his
first evidence that he had tuberculosis
and he wrote this drop of blood spells
my death or this drop of blood it spells
my death because he was trying to write
iambic Lee yeah so I think we're all
just I think we're all just John Keats
just trying to make sure that we don't
have tuberculosis I think that John's
not wrong I
there definitely is diagnosis that you
can do with with snot colors actually
there isn't there is a growing body of
evidence that the that the tradition
that colored snot is bad news and clear
snot is good news is just wrong
I'm not a doctor but I am a person who
googles symptoms a lot and yeah so I
don't think that it is a good way to
tell yourself whether you're sick
obviously if you're coughing up blood or
you have a tremendous amount of blood
coming from really anywhere in your body
then you should see a doctor
honestly if you have any questions about
your health probably don't come to
comedy podcasts probably go to your
doctor yep yep yep though John
apparently has a great deal of knowledge
about about just illness in general and
also what the colors of your snap means
which is apparently not much so don't
worry about it
but I'm really working hard on not not
being so obsessive around my physical
health but it's just not it's not easy
for me it is a great source of
rumination and obsessive thinking
spirals so why don't we just move on hey
I just know I want to say one more thing
to camel this question I want to say one
more thing John maybe two more things
the first thing is I think that I look
at my snot because I want to be
impressed I want to look it down and be
like oh my goodness
really yeah look at me Katherine check
this out
no I don't do that I'm sorry but I think
that there's a part of me that actually
like it wants to know who wants to
select see like how what a massive thing
just exited my body and second to camel
is question I want to say oh my god it's
burning like we haven't done enough
lately so if you really in the oven yeah
or if you might have forgotten to do
something anything if you're waiting at
the airport and you haven't gotten on
your plane yet and you just listen to
this podcast and you're hearing about
this not stuff and you just yeah you got
to remember you're still in the real
world it's time to board your plane time
you know to pass the world is out there
waiting for you but we are moving on to
another question because I am tired of
talking about snot this question is from
Nathan and it's the kind of like deep
penetrating and complicated question
that we love to sink our teeth into Hank
Dear John and Hank coconuts have hair
and produce milk are they
mammals Wow well you know yeah
should-should vegan stop eating them no
no they are not mammals vegans are
welcome to eat all the coconuts they
want because coconuts do not produce
live young but don't they John nope they
don't I guess they do not give birth to
live young that's right that's right
coconuts do not give birth to live young
so vegans rejoice coconut milk is back
on the menu additionally John there is a
there is another important important
characteristic of mammals which is the
three inner ear bones what and coconuts
also do not have ears free inner ear
bones well is that true that all mammals
have three inner ear bones
yeah it's weirdly enough it is one of
the the defining characteristics of
mammals is are the ways that our inner
ear works I do not know why weird I'm
pretty sure yeah pretty sure that I'm
not making this up yeah well I mean do
people come here for like solid factual
science or do they come here to find out
about you know the fact that there was
once a musician who used their farts to
make music I looked it up John it says
mammals this website here which seems
like a legitimate place it says mammals
possess many unique skeletal structures
including a single lower jawbone that
joins to the skull at the squamous bone
and three bones in the inner ear so I
didn't make that up I'm so proud of us
alright so long story short in a
stunning turn of events coconuts are not
mammals yeah and also we're the only
ones who get those three inner ear bones
so the whole rest of the animal kingdom
can just go eat a coconut yeah I mean
sometimes I think Hank about the fact
that if there is life on Mars not to
indulge your silly fascination with Mars
but sometimes I think about the fact
that if there is life on Mars
and it and it it did evolve separately
you know then we could really we could
really learn
pretty deep stuff about for instance you
know is DNA something or RNA something
that can happen independently on more
than one planet or is there a whole
different building block of life that we
don't even have the capacity to imagine
yeah no that's a that's a thing that's a
thing that takes a lot of thinking to
think about yeah I don't know it kind of
blows my mind anytime I try to think
about alien life or even just a
habitable planets outside of Earth it
starts to blow your mind pretty quickly
because you look around the galaxy and
you have to start to contemplate just
how big the galaxy really is I think
we've talked about on the podcast before
about the fact that there are probably
more stars in the universe than there
are grains of sand on earth yeah I think
that the statistic is grains of sand on
all the beaches on earth
I think it's be the safest one okay well
that's a little yeah that still is
troubling to my ability to imagine the
universe you know like ours our Sun
seems like a pretty big deal to be one
grain of sand on all the beaches on
Oliver yes yes and and as far as
chemistry goes we've actually hasn't
talked here on dear Hank and John before
about why water is such a great great
you know solvent for the creation of
complex chemicals and and in life all
right and but but that does not mean
that life could not happen some other
way which is very difficult to think
about like at different pressures at
different temperatures if you have
liquid methane oceans like they do in
some places in our solar system in like
what does that mean and how could right
like like what could dissolve and that
what kind of chemistry can happen inside
of liquid methane at very low
temperatures and that's uh yeah welcome
to welcome to the peculiarity of the
universe and and and
the way the ways and and even the fact
that life works on America on America on
earth is America on our own earth is
really remarkable and and it's it's a
good like the more I know about it the
more sort of wonderful it is the more
wonder I experience observing it I have
to I have to just jump on that Freudian
slip he just made Hank because I think
it's a very interesting one the fact
that you called you referred to the
earth as America I just think that's
interesting because we're constantly in
you and I both and also most Americans
are constantly referring to the United
States as America when in fact America
is two continents of which the United
States is a small part yes a small part
of one yes yes well as as you may have
heard America dang it and do we have a
lot of the people not really know what
were America so who cares we don't have
a lot of the people we do have a unique
gift for narcissism and and for viewing
our particular slice of America as being
in some ways you know unique and
exceptional well you know um the United
States of America does not have the most
people but I bet you John
that it does have the most corndogs and
[Laughter]
also I bet the most podcasts okay let's
move on to another question since that's
what this podcast is ostensibly about
this one is from Kelsey who writes Dear
John and Hank my mom and I are going to
visit her childhood best friend this
summer it all sounded great until my mom
told me that her friend is a minister
and that she's going to baptize me while
we're there for one reason or another my
parents never found time to baptize me
when I was a baby and now that I'm 20
I'm not sure that I even want to be
baptized I know that John would say I
should use my words and tell her about
my uncertainty but when I tried to
explain that I might not even believe in
God she essentially told me that I
didn't know what I was talking about and
that getting baptized isn't really a
choice long story short is there any way
to avoid hurting my mom while also
staying true to what I believe or don't
believe any advice even if
dubious would be greatly appreciated
Hank and I are going to disagree in our
answer Kelsey well I don't know that I
maybe even gonna be able to come up with
one so you go ahead and go first all
right here is my answer
just get baptized it's not gonna hurt
you
it's not gonna hurt anything you'll be
fine it doesn't matter that's my
solution and I don't think Hank is gonna
agree with that at all
well I that was a that was as close as I
was gonna get to an answer I mean like
oh you agree with this just get baptized
yeah there's just get baptized but then
there's a larger thing is like is it
just get baptized and also just don't
tell your mom about the things that you
believe ever no I don't think that
here's I mean my argument in favor of
just getting baptized is that it will
bring great joy and comfort to your
family while hurting you very very
little because it's just water I mean I
would make sure that it's clean water I
would ask for it to be maybe bottled
water depending on where you're
traveling to but but yeah I mean for me
it's like the the ritual only matters if
you in imbue it with mattering so I'm a
big believer in taking the easy road I
think I might have told you this story
before but when I got married
I had to say have I told you this story
before Hank that I had to say that I was
going to raise my kids in the Catholic
Church because Sarah and I got married
in Catholic Church yes this is I've told
this on the podcast I don't think you've
told it on the podcast but you have told
me this yeah all right well so I called
my dad because I was really upset about
it and my dad you know cuz I'm I'm
Episcopalian which is very similar to
Catholicism but whatever it's different
enough that I felt weird about saying I
was going to raise my kids Catholic and
I apologize in advance to our
hard-working editor Nick for the fact
that he's going to have to bleep my
father's response when I expressed
concern about this because dad said I'll
just say it you think God gives it
[Laughter]
that sounds like dad and I was like I
was like what do you mean just saying he
was like just say it just say you'll
raise your kids Catholic and don't mean
it it's fine I
in short Kelsey I think there is a kind
of there is a kind of glory and bravery
to refusing to indulge other people's
rituals that matter to other people but
I'm not sure that for me at least it's
the hill that I want to fight and die on
when it comes to my relationships the
relationships that are most important to
me in my in my family and you know what
yeah I ended up baptizing both of my
kids Catholic so there you go really
teaching no no I think I baptize them
Episcopalian but like I said it's almost
the same
there's nothing involved in both yeah
John just remembers the kneeling I think
that rituals are valuable whether or not
you have all of the bits that people
tend to go into them with you know like
like there is a tradition to baptism
that is I think greater and I might
catch flack for this but I think greater
than the religious component on its own
so there may be reasons to get baptized
that don't even have anything to do with
church and and that I think might even
extend beyond just you know having a
more stable relationship with your with
your mom I I like a lot of religious
traditions I'm not a religious person I
was also baptized and confirmed even and
and I was confirmed after I you know
sort of like came to the place where I'm
at with regards to how I feel about
religion and that was just you know it's
just part of like the tradition of my my
culture and I am fine with having that
tradition those traditions be a part of
my culture even if I don't have don't
share all of the same beliefs as the
people who
and like in like experience have in the
same way as a religious person yeah I
mean I do think our advice on this one
is a little bit dubious because I think
sure especially I think there's a
there's a definite case to be made that
you've got a stand for your principles
especially when they're important to you
I just think that in the case of I think
you're right Hank that in the case of
baptism and a lot and a lot of other
religious traditions like it's possible
to find a value in them outside of the
the religious component that said like I
you know we both think of baptism very
very differently from the way that that
some especially Protestant traditions
think of baptism and so you know I think
different people are going to approach
it in different ways and you know
certainly if you know if you only
believe in adult baptism and or what
it's called adult baptism a lot of times
it happens when you're like seven or
eight in in some some churches but if
you only believe in like ostensibly
adult baptism and that like baptism is
this central moment in your life from
which there is no turning back then I
think you have to have a long
conversation with your mom that's
probably going to be an unpleasant one
but but yeah I mean I I don't know I
again like that's not that's just not
how like you know my kids were both
baptized when they were three months old
and they had absolutely no idea what was
happening to them and and they're going
to make their own religious decisions
you know when that time comes and I hope
that you know I hope that Sarah and I
are able to be part of that but I don't
expect that we're going to be the center
of whatever decisions they make I think
that sometimes it's important to
remember that cultural change happens
too too rapidly for some people and
there's and and like protecting them
from that is not necessarily the kind of
lie you need to be ashamed of yeah I
don't know I'm a big fan of I'm a big
fan of certain kinds of Lies as you know
I think I think lying is tremendously
underappreciated by the social order I
think there are lots of times when
yeah like I don't know what our mom
growing up called little white lies I
love them I'm a big believer in them
yeah I mean you got to simplify
sometimes we've got we've got an update
here from Kai who says dear Hank and
John CAI did the math and determined
that indeed I did talk more than John
did in episode 32 it happened I talked
for 23 minutes and 26 seconds well John
including the short poem spoke for 23
minutes and 14 seconds so I beat you
John if I 13 seconds Oh No
yeah no by 3 seconds by 3 seconds
I'm bad at math I beat you by 3 seconds
John nope I did it wrong again I beat
you by 12 seconds John I kept looking at
the wrong number I know 12 seconds I
beat you you won't ever happen again I'm
wondering how long it's gonna take you
for you I'm wondering how long it's
gonna take for you to figure out that
I'm not talking in the hopes that all of
the dead airtime is counted as your time
I don't think that's how that works
alright in an attempt to not talk too
much the airtime I'm gonna read the next
question very very quickly Hank
alright this question is from Stephanie
who writes dear John Hague would it be
weird if I started using the phrase at
the turn of the century to refer to the
early 2000s no I think that's I think
it's about time no it's not time yet
it's too soon it's got to happen
eventually no you know we just got out
of the period where for a long time
people said 2001 2004 2012 and we're
just entering the period now where
people are saying 2015 because people
aren't gonna say like 2086
they're gonna say 2086 yeah so we've
just crossed that line I think we need a
solid five more years 2021 I think is
the year you can start saying at the
turn of the century referring to the
turn of the 21st century you know I
would really like to see when at the
turn of the century first started
happening for the 1900s I bet you're
right I bet it's I bet it's further in I
bet it's in the 20s or 30s but maybe
even later than that maybe like 50 60 70
si
no III think that we got a we got a ask
Google Google knows this stuff yes yes
no Google is uh oh my god do you want to
know something amazing what John it was
1921 are you serious
that's according to Google no way
I'm a genius I just I just can't I just
can't I am a genius
how you read me this thing that you have
found turn-of-the-century
from 1921 as an adjective phrase that is
from etymology online I mean there's no
reason that that would be wrong now wait
let me go to the Wikipedia page for turn
of the century I mean I don't like to
criticize media but this is a terrible
terrible Wikipedia page the turn of the
century Wikipedia page leads much to be
desired if you're looking to expand
Wikipedia by the way did yep oh wow well
I've got I've got the Google Books in
Graham viewer right now it does actually
it it takes all books published and it
and it max marks them by year and when
people say the the phrase and and I can
say that indeed it began to appear with
some regularity in the 20s and and then
and then oh my god 1921 2021 is
obviously that's it that's the obvious
answer if it was first used in 1921 that
means that 2021 is when you can begin to
use turn of the century to refer to the
most recent turn of the century I am a
genius Google has confirmed it
I would like to retire from podcasting
victorious I'm walking away stumbling a
game Hank a turn of the century
continued to grow until 1980 when it
flattened off then began to decrease in
1994 people stopped using turn of the
century so we're gonna have to see we're
gonna have to wait and see if if we see
another dip and then a bump again my
concern is what do we now call
the turn of the last century the turn of
the 18 to the 19 well Hank it doesn't
matter because I've just retired as a
podcaster victorious like Michael Jordan
walking out at the top of the game like
Peyton Manning walking away a Super Bowl
winner I'm gonna drink a lot of
Budweiser tonight Hank well I would not
expect anything else
question mark Budweiser really is that
the thing that they drink did you not
did you not see the Super Bowl I can't
say the head did is that okay
are you kidding me did you I mean how do
you not participate in one of the
fundamentally American social events of
the year like that
like the wait love that I can't believe
that you didn't watch the Super Bowl
okay so in the Super Bowl which was won
by the den I didn't know that I did I
did see who was the worst related
franchise out of Colorado the captain
and star player of the Denver Broncos is
72 year old Peyton Manning who has had
like neck fusion surgery 14 times and
cannot even like bend over to tie his
own shoes but is somehow still the
starting quarterback of the Denver
Broncos after the game when asked
whether he was going to retire he
answered by saying I'm gonna talk to my
family I don't think that now is the
time for rash decisions I'm just looking
forward to drinking a lot of beer
tonight with my teammates and then he
paused and then he looked directly in
the camera and said I'm going to drink a
lot of Budweiser wow this is a critical
moment in the history of advertising
Hank
because what's most interesting about
Peyton Manning's statement I'm going to
drink a lot of Budweiser is that by all
accounts he was not paid to say that so
he just he but he has previously been
paid by Budweiser
I don't know that he has actually but he
does own a portion of a few
anheuser-busch distributors
oh well that's that that's that's
different that's different right but
that's still that's still marketing what
I thought was most interesting about it
is that like it's in a way isn't he even
if he's not being paid to say it doesn't
he know that he will
be paid to say it if he says it you know
what I mean like if I just won the Super
Bowl and I said I just want to say how
much I appreciate the help that diet dr.
pepper brought to me on this day
delicious diet dr. pepper my favorite
beverage for my entire adult life like
even if I even if diet dr. pepper wasn't
paying me to say that I know that I
could like call diet dr. pepper
afterwards and be like hey did you see
the thing that I did that first ones
free right exactly exactly I bet you
enjoyed that and given how much you
enjoyed it why don't you pay me five
million dollars to do it again uh yeah I
mean additionally you could also go up
there and say like you know I just won
the Super Bowl you know I'm gonna go do
watch crash course on YouTube you will
crash the educational videos and then
people would go watch crash course and
that would be then that's right you own
and you would be making that like
directly like the way that Peyton
Manning apparently owns some
anheuser-busch distributors what a weird
world right exactly so I just think like
we've come to this weird place in
advertising where we can't even take
people seriously when they say things
that they aren't being paid to say
because on one level or another
everything that you say when you have a
large platform you're being paid to say
or you're at risk of like getting paid
in retrospect or seven so it's almost
like we've destabilized these once
trustworthy voices so much that we can't
trust them no matter what they're saying
no matter what the motivation is we can
always cast doubt upon that motivation
and it just seems like a really weird
time to have a flat I'm gonna go drink a
lot it's funny that he said Budweiser -
who says Budweiser no one says that I'm
gonna go have some buds I'm gonna drink
a lot of buds I don't know but you know
it clearly worked because I I found
myself immediately saying you know it's
Sunday night and you can't buy alcohol
in Indiana on Sundays because we live in
the turn of the previous century and but
gosh I wish I could so that I could
enjoy some delicious Budweiser's I do
not ever feel that way and that's maybe
one reason why I didn't want to watch
the Superbowl because I didn't want
people to make me feel like I needed
that
because I didn't well but then Hank at
this point you can't listen to anybody
with a platform saying anything online
are off which means that you know well
from Weird Al Yankovic too they might be
giants to whatever other stuff you like
everybody's voice has become compromised
so I don't know I don't think that you
can get out of it just by not watching
the Super Bowl but maybe we should move
on to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon before we do that I have
another update
John this one is from everyone on
Twitter who has found a 4-sided banana
everybody's got foresighted bananas John
it's really not unusual and they tend to
be trapezoidal so that's an if
information we have now so we think that
that a four sided banana is somewhere on
the scale between finding a penny on the
sidewalk lucky and four-leaf clover
lucky it's it's not that common but it's
not that rare but if you do find a four
sided banana we're gonna go ahead and
say that that's a lucky banana and you
should eat it with pride graduations on
your lucky trapezoidal bananas America
and other places and other places that
we're not sure exists or not you out
there other places who knows oh man all
right Hank what's the news from Mars
this week well at the turn of the
century nope that was not at the turn of
the Year last year let's just say that
last year NASA did a did a challenge
asking people to to figure out whether
or not it was possible to 3d print
places to live on the surface of Mars
because obviously it is a bad idea to
try and bring your house with you when
you're going to Mars because things are
very heavy and it's hard to get them
through space when he got it when he got
it speed no speed them up and slow them
down so there are a number of companies
that entered this this challenge one of
them was red works and I just saw I just
was sent a link to a video of the sort
of concept art for these 3d printed
Martian habitats and I was very excited
about it so I just wanted to
just wanted to share that if you want to
check it out you can check out 3d
printed Martian habitat it's a pretty
cool thing that that NASA did and it
recently announced the the winners for
that challenge so pretty cool and that
yeah so is the idea that you would bring
a printer to Mars and then use like
Martian soil to print a habitat yeah
yeah so you'd use like Martian soil
combined with you know stuff you might
draw to the air or water or you know
what what have you it to basically might
be creating bricks you might be you
might actually be laying down what would
sort of be like concrete but like in you
know like you sort of lay down the
concrete in a line and then you know
come back again when it's dried so it
would be a slow process but but you
would be able to build airtight durable
dome things that you could then go live
inside of and probably they wouldn't
have windows so that's a bit of a bummer
but maybe you could figure out how to
make some windows from some Martian
silica and and and have those as well
though thinking about that I probably
would rather we given the lack of
magnetic field or atmosphere I would
rather have a pretty thick slab of
something between me and that giant
radioactive Death Star up in the sky
today's podcast is brought to you by
that giant radioactive death star up in
the sky that giant radioactive death
star up in the sky
turns out there's as many of them as
there are grains of sand on all the
beaches on earth the podcasts brought to
you by uh that giant amount of snot that
just exited your body wow that is a lot
well just look at that whoa neat I
really did that hey hey somebody look
somebody look and of course this podcast
is brought to you by the year 1921 the
year 1921 confirming my genius since
1921 podcast is finally brought to you
by rock gas a new genre of music and
also what happens to lava when it gets
even hotter
oh man Dylan's parents are just gonna be
absolutely delighted with us for
introducing Rock gas into Dylan's life
oh yeah well Hank I have exciting news
from AFC Wimbledon I have sad news I
have happy news like life itself AFC
Wimbledon is complicated it contains
multitudes first off the under-18 teams
incredible run through the FA Youth Cup
has come to an end
they played Chelsea as we're recording
this they played Chelsea yesterday they
lost it was 1:1 at halftime the dream
was alive thanks to a goal from south
London's ginger Messi Alfie Egan 17 year
old Alfie Egan a hero and the scholar
and a brilliant brilliant footballer but
sadly in the end AFC Wimbledon's youth
team lost to Chelsea
I mean Chelsea was one of the strongest
youth squads in the world so not a huge
surprise but it was a great great
performance nonetheless and an amazing
run through the FA Youth Cup for the
young Dons and then the senior team Hank
was scheduled to take on as I'm sure
you'll recall Bristol Rovers in a
critical critical matchup but then that
game in the end was won not by AFC
Wimbledon or by Bristol Rovers but by
surprise League two leaders waterlogged
pitch aa waterlogged pitch waterlogged
pitches has been an incredible year
across League two he he's just been
dominant every time you think that that
one team or another is going to win a
game it's won by water logged pitch
instead so that game was was put off due
to waterlogged pitch and will be played
in the glorious future when all things
are still possible alright I have a
couple of updates I know I've had
several updates already but I just can't
help myself I said last episode that
that bacteria I just was metaphorically
sort of whimsically using the phrase
cell wall to to indicate some kind of
defense back to you defense mechanism
for bacteria bacteria do in fact have
cell walls and I was saying like if only
they had cell walls but they do have
cell walls and whatever but
just wanted to make sure that everybody
was on the same page here
I was using that as a floral language in
fact it is a technical thing and they do
have them secondarily I just want to say
John I found a podcast or a couple weeks
ago that is great for it it's a few
brothers three brothers not two but
three and they answer people's questions
and give them dubious advice uh-huh and
their podcast has been going on for
about five years and it's really good
and I feel a little like I stole their
idea I promise I didn't it's called my
brother my brother and me it's very
funny it is basically I mean it's so
much funnier it's it's funny it's
actually funny which is how you know
it's funny or the dear Hank and John we
do set a low bar to jump over yeah they
talk almost none about death which is a
little bit disappointing but they they
answer questions both from their viewers
and from Yahoo Answers it's very funny
I've been listening to it at the gym and
I often almost hurt myself because you
need to be careful that you never know
when they're gonna make you laugh way
too hard so my brother my brother and me
is a great podcast on iTunes we didn't
steal their idea but if you want a
comedy podcast with more brothers yet
more brothers these the McElroy brothers
rather than the green brothers giving
dubious advice and answering questions
there's another one every single week
and it you will enjoy it differently and
I'm not gonna say whether you'll enjoy
it more that's for you to decide
listener we also want to thank everybody
who supports the podcast on patreon we
really really appreciate it we got to do
a one of our monthly Hangouts with our
patrons last week it was super fun so if
you want to be part of that or support
dear Hank and John directly you can do
that over at just Google patreon dear
Hank and John and it'll take you right
there Hank what do we learn today Oh
John you know we learned that there's a
six-year-old out there who thinks I've
named Frank
[Laughter]
it's hard to know if he thinks that
you're named Francoeur or if his parents
do or indeed if it was perhaps just a
typo but um I'm gonna call you Frank for
the rest of my life now don't do that we
learned that coconuts are not mammals we
learned that Nicky is is more of a
screech than a Lisa no matter what her
friends say and of course we learned
that 1921 was the year that turn of the
century was first used as an adjective
phrase and that therefore just as I
predicted 2021 is the correct year to
begin referring to the turn of the new
century all right well I'm glad that we
have established this reality for the
world whenever somebody talks about that
I'm tasking all of our listeners to to
not allow anyone to use the phrase turn
of the century in regards to the
nineteen to twenty switch until 2021
police that with great vigor everywhere
you've got thanks again for listening
you can send us questions at Hank and
John at gmail.com or via twitter using
the hashtag dear Hank and John I'm Hank
green on Twitter Hank is John Green on
Twitter thanks to Nicholas Jenkins for
editing this podcast our theme music is
by gunnarolla and as we say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]